cette semaine les députés de l'Assemblée
ont reconnu comme génocide Lolo de mort
une des pages les plus sombres de
l'histoire de l'Ukraine un geste vu
comme un symbole fort le président
zellenski a lui-même salué le vote dans
un tweet mais de quoi parle-t-on
exactement l'eau de mort ou
extermination par la fin c'est la grande
famille orchestrée par l'URSS qui a
touché le peuple ukrainien au début des
années 30 en 1929 Joseph Staline décide
d'un grand tournant les fermes sont
nationalisées 30% des récoltes sont
prélevées les paysans Ukrainiens
insatisfaits de la réforme se soulève
Moscou craint une rébellion nationaliste
et instaure une répression sanglante
toujours plus de nourriture et
réquisitionnée plongeant le peuple dans
la misère au total le lot de mort aurait
fait jusqu'à 8 millions de victimes au
pire de la famine des milliers de
paysans et leurs familles mouraient
chaque jour mais alors pourquoi
l'assemblée choisit de reconnaître Lolo
de mort maintenant 90 ans après pour
dans longtemps on avait peu
d'informations sur cette période l'URSS
gardaient les archives historiques et
elles n'ont été que partiellement
dévoilées à la chute du bloc soviétique
mais en décembre dernier le Parlement
européen a ouvert la voie en
reconnaissant le génocide cette mesure
elle a évidemment une résonance
particulière en pleine guerre en Ukraine
Anne je noter la député Renaissance qui
a présenté le texte a dit que la
résolution visait à dénoncer les crimes
du stalinisme un moment où Vladimir
Poutine essaye de le réhabiliter